these people are just liars and baboons
and they will do anything for politics
and of course the best thing you can do
for politics is destroy your opponents
and sort of wish death on people here's
Joy Behar from The View this is the
quote from Governor DeSantis about
climate change quote I am not in the
pews of the Church of the global warming
leftists this is what he thinks about
climate change and now his state is
getting hit with one of the worst
hurricanes perhaps
Joy you have no idea if this is anything
to do with climate change you have just
simply no idea what DeSantis is saying
is just because the media and the left
say that this is all climate change and
all of these things and AOC says we have
12 years to live and all of this stuff
it doesn't mean any of it's true it
simply does not mean any of it's true
and there's there's also a certain a
certain Joy right she Joy she's Joy
Behar she's actually quite joyless but
when people are being hurt in a place
that she doesn't like then there's a
certain Joy there like you see he's
saying this while his state gets hit
really really it's just so incredibly
dumb anyway here is more of DeSantis
last night and let's contrast that with
let's contrast Joy they are with what it
sounds like to be a real leader and a
little bit of where is Biden
when a natural disaster like this
strikes a state it is it is common it's
I I think it's always the case that the
state receives federal aid given how
politicized things are at the moment are
you confident you're going to get the
federal support Florida needs
so I actually spoke with the president
and he said he wants to be helpful so we
did submit a request for reimbursement
for the next 60 days at a hundred
percent uh that's uh significant uh
support but it's a significant storm so
we haven't heard back from it but I'm
actually cautiously optimistic that we
do I mean as you say tucker we live in a
very politicized time but you know when
people are fighting for their lives when
their whole livelihood is at stake when
they've lost everything if you can't put
politics aside for that uh then you're
just not going to be able to so I'll
work with anybody who wants to help the
people of Southwest Florida and
throughout our state amen
yeah
that's what a leader does that's what a
leader is supposed to say it's not all
about politics and I am going to for a
moment uh give Joe Biden the benefit of
the doubt for just one moment and I
understand he's not in charge and all
that stuff I'm going to give whoever's
pulling the strings the benefit of the
doubt for the moment and assume that
they are going to do the right thing
here and make sure that Florida gets all
of those federal funds uh and that
they're not going to somehow punish
Florida because they don't like that
Florida's become red or they don't like
Governor to say this there's simply no
doubt that the administration at some
level would love DeSantis to take a hit
here right it's just how politics is
it's just reality but I'm going to hope
that they uh do the right thing and and
again whatever I can do over the next
months and years I mean some of this
stuff is going to take years I'm
absolutely going to do it because I am
full of gratitude for the state the
people that live here for Florida man
for the Gators and the iguanas and the
frogs and everything else and uh there's
there's work to do